okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel
thank you for your patience um we had
some guest issues today so
um i appreciate the patience i know you
guys have been waiting for a second
before i start guys do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
as you guys know super chats will be red
okay what's up guys so if you guys want
just pearly things youtube channel
thank you for your patience um we had
some
guest issues
today so
um i appreciate the patience i know you
guys have been waiting for us before i
start guys do not forget to subscribe to
the channel and bring that notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos i think as
you guys know super chats will be red
okay what's up guys so if you guys want
just pearly things youtube channel
thank you for your patience um
guys do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos i think as you guys
thank you for your patience um we had
some he makes you guest issues
today so
um i appreciate the patience i know you
guys do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos i think as you guys know
super chats will be red okay what's up
guys
[Music]
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos i think as you guys know
super chats will be read okay what's up
guys
youtube channel
thank you for your patience um we have
something
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos
i appreciate the patience i know you
guys have been waiting for us and before
i start
guys do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification so
that we are going to be notified of my
daily videos
as you guys know super chats will be red
okay what up guys
um
thank you for your patience
okay is that better maybe
it's weird because it's the same one as
last time
i know that's what i'm wondering too
um
hold up mixer
that's right
um
that's so weird
no because that's not it because that's
muted
but it's like really weird
the echo just stopped okay i think it
was the desktop audio
let me just double check on the stream
make sure i can hear it
you
okay yeah better sorry guys sorry about
that okay
technical difficulties there's always
there's more to this stuff than you
think okay so welcome to the show
appreciate you having me again
you get to be the star today how do you
how does it feel
you know what it is it feels okay you
know
it's ram i'll put the team on my back
you know i know how it is
okay so today's topic
is men
say they don't care about a woman's
money
so i want to get your perspective from
the man's point of view do you if you're
trying to date a girl do you care how
much money she makes
um it depends on how far you are in the
like relationship
i feel like because um if you're just
starting out and you're just getting to
like you know the honeymoon stage the
three-month honeymoon stage
like it matters too much and then
obviously after that if you see yourself
like living with her and making a future
with her then it does help knowing like
the income of both sides of the both
parties because it just benefits you in
um in a way that's like
you know how much you're making she's
you know how she what she's making you
know how much you need to put aside for
like rent
and like the necessities to live
and then everything else on top of that
i don't feel like that's really
necessary for you to know so if a girl
you find out she makes six figures
does that make you more attracted to her
less attract is it like nothing
personally myself money is not really i
don't see money as like
whether you're going to be attractive or
not it's like
i don't
characterize that as that because
obviously when i'm when i'm a person i
meet them for what they are before i
know how much they make and before i
know like um what's like what's the
annual income type thing right so i
don't know i wouldn't you can't you can
kind of tell though with people just
like basically style yeah of course like
i've had um
i've had one of my exes
actually like she um she dressed like a
like a model and she looked good but
like i would like i didn't know
like until later down the line about how
much she made but that didn't make me
like
less or more attracted to her which just
made me like oh yeah
because like i don't base my
relationships on like how much she makes
like oh how much i make because that's
just um
that kind of like puts me on like a
negative point that's like oh i'm only
with you for the money time yeah
have you have you heard like women that
will talk about how much money they make
and how much like how much they bring to
the table i can't actually though yes um
i've heard i've seen videos i've seen
sick talks i've seen um
like
women in movies as well like when they
make six figures they think they're like
you know they're all that like flipping
their hair like oh i spent like 200
pounds like dollars or pounds on on
nails and it's like well good for you
but like i got the same you know like
another woman that's less fortunate
oh i've got exactly the same thing for
cheaper so it's like it's just like um
money is more like a like a flex right
so a lot of women like if they get like
once they get started making a lot of
money like a lot like six figures and up
it's like i don't need a man like that's
when you get those like oh i'm an
independent woman like i didn't need a
man it's almost it's almost like no they
might as well say i can't get a man
well no that's the thing they
not the guy they want yeah no it would
never be the guy they wanted just
because like
because the women that like
the women like the wealthy women of the
world mm-hmm that are smart with their
money yeah and have husbands right
uh-huh they dress like it's it's like
it's like this theory right you could be
standing next to a millionaire but you
will never know because the smart people
they don't go for like expensive and
like the most expensive cars and stuff
like that and so wealthy women do the
same thing it's like you will never know
you're since you're standing next to a
billionaire or whoever because they
dress a certain way they don't dress
like everyone else like they don't
follow the trend they dress like because
i'm sorry that's how they stay wealthy
when like they buy like you know the
regular things that everyone else buys
rather than buying the gucci's and the
products right that's the same with um
so you would never know
whether a woman is like that but the
people that do socialize it like the
rich right they socialize it because
they think they've got their little five
minutes of fame and they've got money
well and a lot of times the people that
buy that [ __ ] can't afford it like they
have a lot of debt like trying to keep
up with that
no and it's because honestly i grew up
like i grew up in a wealthy family like
my dad's like does very well
and
like he's the cheapest person i've ever
met in my life
that's why the wealthy wealthy yeah
because like the people that like be
advertised you know socially like um my
friend is like but i'm not no no no name
dropping but my friend is like the
perfect example he um
sorry he and she actually did that
together they would go out and they
would like they work like a regular day
job right there but then like the stuff
they buy they save up for months right
and then they would go out clubbing and
they buy the biggest table and stuff
like that but then you have like
whatever comes with the table they would
never buy more because they can't afford
it and it's just like why would you go
out of your way to spend that amount of
money on a piece of clothing that looks
good right but then you can spend
less
and you have money to spend on the club
right
so that's why it's like well so
so you're you're 22. yeah
so i'm assuming when you date you don't
really date like looking for like a wife
that's a drop that's actually a job
because no i'm one
this is just this is going to make me
sound so old
i do
i really do because like it was fun when
i was like 17 and 18 and 19 but like
about 22. when you're no no no no no
even
i was 17 18 and 19. and it's just like
you know girl off the go and stuff like
that you know you have sex and whatever
and you date them for like
a month or two
pick up another one 16 no no it's 16 17
17 18 is that are these streets like
wild in london they're not wild but i
think they're always seven
i went to catholic school it was a
little different
i used to have like well i used to have
game i still do but it's just like i
just don't enjoy the hunt much anymore
like i just know now if i find like
so you know that i like so let's say did
you like i would probably be like would
you get married
at some point
no but the reason i'm asking because
like the reason i'm bringing up like why
men should like think about money right
is because if you marry a girl that has
money like legally you're at more of an
advantage like she can't take half of
your stuff later
you know do you know what i'm saying
yeah i know because obviously if it
doesn't work out in the marriage it's
like i'm gonna take half your stuff well
i don't have half of it so what are you
taking that thing yeah yeah i get what
you say well because i i i messaged this
attorney that's in the manosphere you
guys know the lead attorney i'm sure you
guys do
um and i asked him i said
all right i said let me find it
i said
yes you were right men are and better
placed in a divorce to the extent
that the difference in the spouse's
individual net worth is minimal when
there is a large disparity that's when
men or women if they are the bread and
winner can get screwed over
so
that's that's the only reason i was
saying like maybe men should think about
it
if they have like a good chunk of change
you know what i mean
no but then you know what i said you
have those women that's like if you have
the the woman that's like that makes a
lot of money in a relationship and then
the man is just like
kind of like a stay-at-home husband type
thing yeah and she just runs you over
like as funny as it sounds like there's
a woman like she wears the pants in the
room would you be a stay-at-home husband
absolutely not absolutely i couldn't do
it absolutely not i like making my own
money like like i can't have someone
turn around and be like yeah you be like
[ __ ]
hell no i can't do that i'm sorry
i'd like to say i i like to you know i
have my own income my own money to like
to where like i can spend my own in the
way i want to spend more money
and not have anyone to look back and be
like is that different is that because
you're from lithuania
no i have always liked me no no i'm just
asking is it culturally different there
is it more traditional than like it's
in in a lot of different countries
especially like
like european countries it's like it is
a little bit different because it's like
it's all about the savings because the
tax in lithuania is so high not just for
the tax so like let's say um my friend's
uncle right he works in just a regular
construction job makes a lot of money to
on paper makes about 2100 right but he
only sees about a thousand of that money
because of 30 i think it's like i don't
know about the tax rate it's like 37
percent it goes to the tax and then
another percentage goes to the
healthcare but then when you go to the
hospital you still have to pay for the
majority of the stuff so where does the
health care kick in and it's supposed to
be like it's good healthcare but then
everyone is just on a savings because
like the money that you get in your euro
compared to the money you get here it's
two different things and it's like
people go to save a lot like a lot like
that's that's why it's like advised
you have to get a house like buy
something that's your own
i want you to speak into the mic a
little more i am speaking to the mic
i think you gotta lean forward oh my
dance okay
yeah how's that
is it better guys let us know in the
chat i know we got it's been a rough i'm
normally a loud person
i'm fully i'm normally well it's kind of
hard because usually it's like a group
and so like you you kind of it kind of
gets like people going but it's when
it's one-on-one it's a little different
yeah keep it down
no because i always wonder
i've what i've found is eastern europe
europe seems to be a little more
traditional than the rest of europe like
you don't think so it used to be used to
be a lot more like when my mom was
raised and stuff like like post-war time
and like everyone's getting back
together in the world and stuff like
that like yeah it used to be a lot
different like the marriages was like
walking down the aisle in a church and
you know wearing a white dress white
talks having the best man there now just
like it is still traditional to an
extent but like it doesn't have to be a
big family wedding you can just be like
a small just family and friends
gathering nothing too expensive nothing
too crazy just you know the man proposes
they get you get uh they get um married
doesn't have to be like a really big
white wedding you know like everyone
every woman dreams of type thing
but you know it's it has drifted apart
away from like the normal
casual wedding that we used to have all
the time do you think that's do you
think it's good that we're going away
from traditional values or do you think
um society like do you think society's
better without them or do you think it's
there's a reason for them
i mean i would say in one word it's just
evolution to be honest yeah it's like we
had the traditional and there's been
like good we've had it for years and
years and then it's just like someone
one it took one brave couple to be like
listen we're not going to do that this
way and then we started like a trend
and then we just forwarded into like now
we have like i've seen a couple on tick
tock right who got married they they're
quite young right but they got married
like on some like
like it was a real relatively big
wedding but then it wasn't uh
like the normal wedding you would expect
like the woman is dancing so like
cowgirl like the dog yeah man you know
i'm not really talking so much about
like weddings i'm talking about like
everyone's getting married later and
later and later so like my parents my
dad married my mom my mom was 21 i think
he was 26.
and that's like relatively young
nowadays you know in ireland the average
age of first marriage is 35 and 34.
which is mad
and you see like more women not getting
married at all and staying single
like in forever but like i think fifty
percent of women over thirty cat ladies
yeah yeah no but
but
like do you like do you think that's
good for society or
what are your thoughts on that it's
everyone has their time to be honest and
that personally like if you if you feel
like you want to get married young and
you have that mind so like not younger
like if you have the adult mindset early
mm-hmm and the woman that you meet has
in the mindset early why not yeah do you
find the one look like people find the
one like a different do you believe in
the one i don't believe in the one i
mean
it sounds like like it's like you know
what i say like you don't believe in the
one until you find the one you know i
mean it's just like it's just one of
those things it's like everyone finds
the one i don't i don't believe it
i think i think
that's like a disney that's like that's
like a disney come on
people this is i think you make a choice
like you look at the pros and cons of a
person and you make a choice
and you're never gonna know because if
there was a one why would 50 of
marriages end in divorce if there was a
one
because it was the wrong one
i guess i don't think so i think people
just make like like
i don't think there's one person out
there i think you get to make a choice
like kevin hart remembered like three
times before he found the one so then
he'd cheat on her and then i don't know
what happened i thought they were
divorced now yeah they were they were he
got divorced like two times and then he
remembered the third time i think yeah
but like to me that's not the one it's
just yeah it's just like it's just
like i'm just fight i'm trying to find
someone to die with that thing like i
just feel like when we when we push
like society pushes the one it's almost
like they're saying just do nothing
someday you'll just find them like
you'll run into them and it'll just
happen
you gotta you gotta that's the cheesy
part yeah that's really the cheesy place
like oh one day you might look up in the
sky and someone would just bump you in
like oh you fall down it's like that's
like a makeup i just really think
you make choices so you pick who you
date of course so i don't and you you
weigh the pros and the cons of dating
each person and then at some point you
make a choice to get married or not get
married but i feel like the reason
people are so afraid of like marriage
and like pushing it off and not doing it
partially is because the laws one don't
favor men that's like definitely a
problem
and the second one is that there's this
like
sense that there's just one person
everyone's just gonna know and like have
these crazy feelings and stuff and i
just don't think it's like that i think
you make a choice and run with it
i mean there is some truth to that of
course because obviously like at the end
of the day is a choice but like i'm
saying the one because obviously it's
just like this is that's what like
everyone's like falsely made to believe
social media wise it's like oh you know
those stories are making believers just
like any disney movie oh you bump into
someone and it's like oh love at first
sight something because lover first i
don't i don't i don't believe in love at
first
i would definitely believe like in the
one before i believe that love at first
sight because it's just like love at
first i just like oh my god it's just
like she's so beautiful so no that's
yeah she's like oh
it don't i think some people maybe got
lucky you know what i mean
but and lucky doubles
wait so
um
okay wait what's my next question
what
would you rather have
a girl
like so so is money nothing to you like
if a girl made fifty thousand or a
hundred fifty thousand is that like
you'd literally pick either
personally like i said i like making my
own money so money to me is like it's a
material thing money will always come
and go like for example the way i look
at where i see money right is like if
you have the 100 if you make a hundred
pounds if you make 200 pounds 300
whatever it may be right yeah let's say
there's a there's like a concert that
you want to go to right
and then you choose not to
but then if you look at it like what if
i went there you spend that hundred
pounds you make the hundred pounds the
next week and the week after you won't
even remember it for down the line
because it's just something that like
you'll remember the the best night of
your life because you went out with your
friends you did that rather than you
stayed at home and saved 100 pounds you
know what i mean do you do you think
it's wrong that like women look at money
so much
absolutely really i'm sorry i don't i
don't think it's wrong i don't think i
don't i don't think it should be money
alone it shouldn't be money at all but
that's what like i don't think like i
don't think women should be dating like
bombs
like guys that like refuse to work oh oh
no
i'm not talking about like a guy that's
like young and like trying to build
himself up that's one thing but like
like losers i feel like we should i just
i just i just i just think like girls
like we should probably avoid losers
like you know what it is as cheesy
sounds you're only attracted to like
like like punk kid like the ones that
are like
that
see red pill guy is a little he's a
little red pill
we're only attracted
to the jerks jerks
you're attracted to the jerks i'm sorry
yes no because it's like
most from what i've seen in the past
relations right when i i went through
the whole jerk face myself when i was
just like i would you you were the jerk
i was the jerk for like what did you do
wasn't a savage thing you've done oh my
god no
it's not but that's the thing it's not
what i did it's how i got it's how i got
the girls that's why that's why i was
like when i was 18 years old right i
couldn't give a girl a time of day
uh-huh like but that's just what made
them like i would talk to her like i
would talk to her and so i'm like yo
what are you saying like it was just
quick
quotes yeah there's like quick messages
and then they'd be like oh well you
never know and whatever come over if you
want to use and i would give them like
some some stuck-up answer i'll come over
here and i don't really care something
but that's what made them like
oh yeah i'm i'm definitely coming that
you know i mean like that's what that's
what drove himself because it's like
as funny as it sounds like girls are
trying some majority of the girls
attracted to the jerks the drugs i don't
give them my time with them do you know
why
because then i don't know what you tell
me so elaborate expand my horizons so
it's it's because of the dark triad
traits they call them the same traits
that make a man the hero makes him the
villain
so for example the guy that can beat
somebody up and that's aggressive
that's the hero he has to kill the
villain
but that's also the villain he has that
same trait so like women are attracted
to men that are more aggressive on some
level disagreeable men that are
disagreeable tend to make more money
those are the guys that are the ceos but
those are also prisoners
yeah so it's the same it's like the same
traits but on different ends of the
spectrum
that's mad
that's actually mad
guys he is everyone's saying you're blue
pill i don't listen he is blue pill
that's the point what what should i
repel him on guys put stuff in the chat
also guys all super chats are going
towards this studio upgrade i've had a
lot of complaints about this wall
and i'm fixing it soon
so if you guys want to send super chats
it's all going towards the upgrade but
let me know what
i should blue or red tell him on
that's mad
i'm getting drooled out by the chat
well because there's oh my gosh
there's a lot of stuff that goes into it
but
it's interesting because i always say
that money to
men
is like a shoe collection to women
like i do not care about men's shoe
collections i don't i don't care at all
i don't even care a little bit
but like i i always think of like that's
how men see our money it's like nothing
well i would
this is this this is the thing and this
is this is good uh this i'm gonna put a
quote in right now um steve harvey done
actually
so basically what he has said right is
if you're in a if you're already like
let's say you're married or you're about
to get married or you're just living
together then and only then would like
a couple
would
need to know like their incomes and he
explained it through saying every couple
or married couple or getting married
should have four accounts okay four bank
accounts right then the first account is
where you go and put your rent money in
utility one is a necessity basically
anything that's a necessity to live in
you put that in there right
car notes and all that stuff right in
the second account you um put you put
the savings that's a savings account
where you agree to put in x amount of
money at the end of the month whatever
you can put in there and it takes two
signatures to move it right and then the
third and fourth account is her account
and his account that's the money that's
he you you don't have to check in with
me about how i'm spending it and i don't
have to check in about what you're
spending on those are you this is that's
your money and that way everything is
paid for you have a little money to save
for your kids futures or whatever you
want to save on everything like your
house is paid for your electricity's
paid for and you have money to spend on
yourself that's that to me that's like
that's ringing true on on like a lot of
levels because i feel like that would
probably be like the best way to
describe because like you're saving some
money or at the end of every month you
everything's paid for and you have your
money to spend without actually asking
um the other partner about you know so
do you believe in going 50 50 no no no
because
in order in society we're just whole i'm
going to be so controversial look women
don't make as much as money
i'm sorry like yes we do well
now yes i can give you that now but it's
a case of like let's say for example in
a scenario where
let's say i'm working
as like let's say the ceo of i always i
own like a really big company right and
let's say you own
you or you work and as a manager in a
major position right
very well um
sorry where
both have good jobs basically what i'm
going to say and at the end of the month
right like whatever it's going to be
split down into a percentage right so
like if i'm paying 30 percent
on the house
of for for my rental whether it needs to
be film from you no matter if you're
making less or more that way the
relationship that way is like truly
equal so if i'm paying like 15 of what i
earn
oh so you kind of do believe in 50 50 in
a way
yeah it's just a percentage so so let's
say you you date a girl you're making
fifty thousand she's making fifty
thousand
do you believe in fifty fifty
thousand
i i guess in a scenario where you're
making exactly the same amount yes
but still it's like
what if she out earns you do you believe
in 50 50. no
should she pay more no
everything should be everything should
be like equal to say but you're just
like um
no i'm just wondering if you believe
like the men should be providers
oh uh
not so much now like back in the day
absolutely yeah but that was like the
easiest time when women just stayed home
and cooked and cleaned while the men
were going to the woo and making the big
bucks right now because you're full for
your equality and it's like apparently
everything's equal now and stuff like
that
um i'm not for this i want to go back to
the kitchen i want to return our rights
have i told you this no i don't think
you did i literally want to return our
rights but you know what it is okay cool
you've got you uh uh sorry to take this
a bit off topic here we're like all
women like they were
fighting for their eyes and uh you know
it's all like so well and good and now
it's like supposed to be really equal
but that then again means like put to
put in basketball terms does that can a
woman go play nba
if you are truly equal now oh no
i don't want equality i want unequality
i want to put women in the kitchen yeah
okay one okay first of all i would like
to return our right to drive i'm not
good good at driving i think the men
should drive us around return
whoa
you know what i don't mind you don't i
don't i don't really like driving okay
second of all let's let's get rid of our
right to vote while we're at it
why pay attention to politics
why why wait in line in the voting booth
when the guys could just go do it for us
return
see all right cool okay third of all
third of all no no not done not done
right to work
why work
no okay cool well we could just not work
i could be at home chilling doing my
youtube channel not right there but
right return no no in this day and age
no no no no no i disagree on that one
you know why no that's that's a that's a
good thing you put up no i don't
disagree with that because nowadays yeah
i guarantee you
one no about like
um only like eight and two in ten women
yeah sorry two in ten women know how to
cook know how to clean
care of the house
yeah what do you think what is my
apartment
hell nah what no
no i mean yo you know you take you know
you you know you take you take good care
of your puppy but i'm saying like a lot
of the women right now yeah if i told
you like yo go like
because for example my exes i've had
eight right out of those eight only one
neutral cook clean take it the rest of
them like oh i don't do it my parents do
it for me um
i'm like bro that's true you leave you
think women want traditional
men but they're not traditional women
yes yeah yeah that's true
that's like that it's written it was
what you could on for a fresh and fit
there was a word that was like oh it's
written in the bible and the guy was
like oh you're also supposed to be a
virgin yeah exactly like how are you how
are you gonna how do you want a man to
be a conventional man when you're not
conventional you can't
you can't do that like it don't work
like that i'm sorry
no i agree i think but i also
can't really i'm really not that good of
a cook but i'd still like to go back to
the kitchen
okay there's a cookbook somewhere
like online is a beautiful in this
sphere they always say like you don't
cook unless you have a cookbook or like
your own recipes and stuff but i'm like
what 25 year old has a cookbook like i
put in my notes app are you none of you
in 2022 i don't get it
my mom's old school she has she gives a
cookbook but are your parents
traditional very little well um
i would i would say so i mean my mom
keeps it to like a lot of the stuff that
she used to do back when she was younger
so i'd say so
you know not in that comeback you know
obviously because she works she comes
back home so you know
takes a shower that's her whatever eats
and then you know just
kelly usually carries about her day
makes food
and you know cleans up every on the
weekends like they used to back in you
know monday to friday the men work women
clean but obviously now it's just more
like
she cleans up whenever she has to mostly
on the weekends which is normally that's
that's when you normally take care of
the house like you know get the chores
done get the washing up and stuff like
that
do you okay
are you afraid of marriage as a guy like
because of the legal ramifications where
like if you let's say you were like rich
do you think you'd get married
if you if you were like making let's say
six figures
should have to be the one
um
probably yes of course like you know at
the end of the day i feel like i'm gonna
roast you in the chat they're gonna rush
you they're gonna be like blue pill blue
pill
don't do me like that man don't do me
like that no but honestly like
i mean marry i guess gary's marriage is
the way i guess always like i did we did
a segment last year first time i mean i
do believe that marriage is the way
because obviously at the end of the day
it's like
you can i mean you i mean some people
think that like oh you can die happy but
alone like no that's that ain't nobody
ain't nobody dying happy alone like
let's be serious like you need someone
like there that's you know to support
you through the hard time because now we
have a lot of depression nowadays and
it's like sometimes it's just good to
have that person you come home tonight
just like like at the end of the day you
lay down in bed and someone just
scratches your back you know i mean it's
just like as funny as that sounds you
know what i mean so
do you think that
um
do you think when girls say they don't
need a man do you think they're capping
or do you think do you think they
do cup
why i'm sorry cap
who's going to change the light bulb
you know because if you think about it
oh uh certainly grab your mic if you
ever want to yeah at a certain point
it's like okay they might not need a man
now like no i'll agree to a certain
degree of course of course because like
if you look at it like oh you know i'm
an independent woman i don't need no man
and stuff like that but then like at a
certain age a woman will actually
realize that like oh [ __ ] like i'm like
i need a man
obviously lesbians i don't i don't know
how they work yeah operate and stuff
like that but obviously in a in a
scenario where a man likes a woman and a
woman
like a certain age i feel like everyone
realizes that's like
i'm done like my time is done to have
fun i need to like find someone and like
settle down
but then like eighty percent of
marriages end in divorce stop giving me
percentages man i can't work with it i
don't think it was 80. is it really 80
guys i thought it was 50. so that
doesn't scare you at all
oh it doesn't scare me either but i'm
also a girl in the court system is
usually on my side but
i was told i should get a prenup
actually that's why i asked those people
you know what it is nowadays girls like
when you get married yeah with a wife
yeah it's like it's almost an insult oh
let's let me sign a prenup like that's
always almost like an insult to
something i think i would i think i'd
get one because
i'm i'm gonna inherit a decent chunk of
change so i'm gonna change
i'll share it if we're married but if
you leave me for a [ __ ] 20 years
younger then i will not be you will not
be taking that how can you be 20 how can
you be six years old going for like a
nah 20 years younger i couldn't do it
like after after like a certain point
like when you reach like the 50s and 60s
like that's what the men are most
attracted to if you survey men from like
20 to 80 on what girls are the hottest
it's like 22.
yeah that's mud like then 22 21
something like that oh no if you're
looking now of course like but you but
like you notice i've always found a
discussion that but after a certain age
it's like what do you think's too big of
an age gap and what's the oldest and
youngest you would date
oh that's a good one um
right now i wouldn't i wouldn't i would
personally i would not date that up uh i
would not dig down sorry right now my
age or down not happening you wouldn't
date a 20 year old you're 22.
no okay why because as funny as it
sounds right
i'm i'm over the whole like like i said
i'm over the chair i'm done with the
chase and stuff like i like cool if the
girls if we click as a thing cool but
that's like
because nowadays it's like a lot of the
people like that my my age people right
that i talk to guys or girls
they'd like they're still living with
the parents right they're still haven't
got a job they're still having like this
you live with your parents yeah but i
know but i have a
i'm studying right right as soon as
that's done i'm out like i've already
said yeah i'm actually no next year when
i'm meeting so you're saying like
there's a lot of guys that are losers
well i want to say losers but like you
need to get your life in check because
like sometimes that i talk to the like
my age people specifically they're still
like
are out drinking i'm partying all night
right and i'm working my also to you
know save money to do what i want to do
you know i mean so it's just like
it's good to have some fun every now and
then but it's like if you if you haven't
gotten your life in order it's like come
on because obviously nowadays women
because obviously with the whole um
women's mature quicker
mentally and physically a lot quicker
than men it's like
you've really got your get your life in
check like because a woman's not going
to go for like a little boy as they
would say you know
because obviously they
they still want to provide and they
still want to know someone to
take care of themselves as funny as that
sounds obviously for me it's like i
would date up
not down purely for the fact that like i
feel like my maturity levels has has
been higher than a normal
um my age person she like the cougars
i want to say
i wouldn't
um i'd probably go as high as like maybe
20
26
26 yeah what but 20 29 too old
too big of a gap for me would be like
like
six
anywhere between six and eight yeah
that's like that's a bit of a stretch
really i don't care i would date i would
do this
okay right now you did a 50 year old yes
or no no yeah so there is like
no there's a cap but i would probably
date a 45 year old
yeah
i've dated i've you met them yeah i've
dated a
39 38 year old
at what age
24.
yeah so that's not that's like
for you
might not be like uh but that's like but
i feel like it's different with girls
like i feel like because girls are
attracted to different things
because because men are attracted to
fertility
and women are attracted to success
so the younger the girl is the more
fertile she is and the older the guy is
the more she is okay daddy
that is true though
most girls most girls are like they be
shaking their ass and they're going to
see like a little sugar daddy like it's
like a successful old black man but then
it's like they like
they go after that like that's that's
the only time they go over they go for
that would you date a girl with an only
fans
you're putting me on blast right now
um
yeah
probably why
i don't
oh you shouldn't like no i told you this
i told you this
keep in mind we had a conversation about
this a while back
but
only the in like the innocent ones no no
not like the ones that do like all that
and crazy nasty okay so what if nudes
you're thinking about this mother of
your children oh no i wouldn't say no
date no you said oh sorry i'm sorry
sorry if we're talking about seriously
seriously dating oh and probably not
then no only fans
no if we're talking just like if it's a
phase and i'm just dating the person
yeah absolutely why not but if we're
talking like long term like she's doing
that nasty stuff and i want to marry her
absolutely not hell no
that's the same as you saying oh would
you ever date would you ever marry a
porn star
no no
no oh my gosh
i had a tick tock that like went kind of
like kind of viral a little bit where i
was saying like
that
like basically saying stop wife and hoes
you know
stop wiping hoes like to the men
just like like why would you date a girl
with an only fans like you should have
standards and no offense if you don't
but
but i was just saying like um
but but people were mad and they were
like oh well i wouldn't like my husband
doesn't judge me and i'm like well i
wouldn't want your husband then because
i wouldn't want to date a guy that would
be okay with that
no no but santa's like stannis are like
it's like if a woman looks a good
attractive yeah and like if you meet her
like without like if i met an only fancy
woman that was attractive and stuff like
but i didn't know she was you know
trying to find out about later
like obviously i'd still i still want to
like see what the where it goes but
obviously wouldn't it be like
the whole
marriage thing would probably be out
non-marriage but like serious thing
would probably be other question i'll be
only because she hasn't known you that
would be like
why would you give a girl a shot with an
only fans
personality i'm sorry that sound is so
bad so no because look it's perfect okay
i don't know put it to the place
put you in a scenario like this right
if i if you met the girl
before you knew shawn you had all your
fans right uh-huh beautiful smart
intelligence she knows like she knows
her stuff right uh-huh and then you got
to to get like together and she found
out oh by the way i'm doing only
fantastic but then you're not exactly
gonna like obviously it's a red flag but
like you obviously go look at the fact
that like you spent x amount of time
with this girl you actually connected
well now on like a deeper level in that
scenario yeah i'd probably see like i'd
probably date the girl but like it
wouldn't be normal no more than like it
wouldn't go as far as like saying
getting to a serious relationship you'd
want to be like because i just wouldn't
want to like i was saying i feel like
who you date is your brand
that's your like personal brand and i
wouldn't want to be associated with
someone with an only fans like i
wouldn't want to be a like not i mean
they could be my friend but not in like
a
a dating way like a romantic way because
i think that says something about my
ability to forget guys and girls right
huh
that's the difference between guys and
girls and i guess like you know
no if anything men should be more turned
off by
than a girl oh my gosh okay
if you if you're okay if you if someone
like you the girl doesn't have an only
fans right but like when you get into
relationships and she wants to like well
that would be a red flag for you like
right now you go into a relationship
like someone goes into a relationship
they don't have only fans but they want
to make one but with that person
is that like a with who with me it
couldn't be me it couldn't be me it
couldn't be me
not me
well like what if you started an only
fans and nobody bought it how
embarrassing would that be
[Laughter]
in a way that's like you a guy meets a
girl they don't have none of them have
only fans right but they decide to meet
like one of them one of these days like
the girls that are i want to make only
friends with you or like a guy that i
want to make an only friend with people
what would you like how would that okay
one
i i
i wouldn't pick someone that would be
okay with that
i wouldn't really no
because it's like you dated for like
let's say a couple months right and she
they decide like one of you one of you
said oh let's make an only fans but
together and while it's in a
relationship you didn't have nothing
before that that's like uh
that's a bit for me i would personally
say if i was in relation someone told me
that she wanted to make a phone i'd
probably be like um i didn't even i
would be turned up by that it's like why
would you want to put all love life on
blog
exactly
no i would not do that all right we got
a super chat
okay wait i can't scroll up let me just
pull it up on my phone
guys all super chats are going towards a
new camera okay
where was the office
huh
it was the office
oh no it's going towards that too we're
getting a studio revamp i've ordered
some equipment so you're going to see
chain updates soon i'm waiting on a
couple more pieces but
thank you thank you but where there's
going to be even more so
um blue pill unplugged a pre-marital
401k the woman is still entitled oh
that's interesting so if you get a
premarital 401k the woman is still
entitled to 50 of the increase during
marriage even if no marital assets were
added to it divorce law was crazy so
if you had a wife
and
i think that's an american because i
don't know what
it
was
um oh actually oh yeah guys guys we're
in europe yeah yeah we're not i'm not
well west with the 401k i don't know the
laws here actually but i have no idea of
the loser on here yeah that much oh my
gosh they're arguing in the in the
comments section if i'm catholic or not
i was raised catholic
interesting oh my gosh
she has sinned apparently yeah
yeah
i'm a bad catholic i guess i don't know
um okay
but thank you appreciate the super chats
all super chats guys if you've watched
five or more lives and you haven't sent
any money
it's offensive i'm doing this [ __ ] for
free for you this is entertainment i do
this for you guys three times a week i
put so much time and effort into this i
have to recruit people
i have to
get this audio equipment i'm spending my
own money i don't even keep the money at
this point so i appreciate the super
chats and you guys should send more so i
can get a new camera okay thank you i'm
done
plug plug plug plug also if any of you
are in london um come on the show
because i'm having trouble getting
guests sometimes
um okay
next question oh dude so they they're
really harping on your age here i think
you're inexperienced and that's why you
don't hate women yet
i mean i've only had eight well eight
relations yeah eight relationships um
you had eight yeah 22
black like eight girlfriends yeah oh wow
okay was that is that too lit is that
bad is that too little i thought that
was a lot that's a lot well
four of them don't really count because
they were like um that wasn't serious
and then the the other four were kind of
were because they were like uh
more of like
the time that we spent the last one was
pretty serious i was like sorry the one
before that was pretty serious because
they had the girl for like two years
two years why did it end
long story long story tell it no tell it
tell it on the podcast
is your mom watching i hope not
i hope not
did you like her put it in the chat
i mean when we first started it like she
was like this is the one i told you that
was like like she was smart like i was i
was still in uh sixth form for those of
you know sixth form
it's like basically we go to college um
early basically
that type of thing um i was started
dating at the start of the year
and she didn't go to my use uh
college but she went to like another one
but we kind of like made that work which
was fairly close and what day she was
smart she was beautiful went to holidays
and stuff like that it's just um
i think it was like it was like more of
like a mutual breakup i wouldn't say
that there was any parties that was like
oh i hate you for something or you there
was no cheating
i think it was just like we just drifted
apart type thing it was kind of like a
mutual feeling rather than like
so she broke it off no no we actually
had to we had to have like well someone
somebody didn't break up it was i'm
going to bring it up
yeah no no no no no of course someone
had to bring up when it's like we got
into i think it's like the argument got
a bit mad and we kind of like sat down
together and was like listen like
where is this going and she like we felt
both like we needed to take that break
apart and then
just turn into a permanent thing and
then that was that
um we tried to like talk and start
things over but then
i was like i was like um we kind of like
you know and then we kind of knocked off
i have a question so have you heard of
an alpha widow
okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna write i'm gonna give
him some red pill facts okay so they
call an alpha widow is like i noticed
this in college okay every girl would
have this one guy that she could not get
over
like it would just be the one like one
dude and i would see like this girl this
girl this girl they would date another
guy
didn't they they were dating him
but they still really wanted the last
guy and they call it an alpha widow
because the girl sees the last guys the
best that she could do
and so she's like widowed almost does
that make sense okay
um
and i was wondering do you think men
have an equivalent of that
no no
i mean
off the top of my head i like put it
into our shoes i don't think that i've
ever been like put in a situation where
like i'm dating someone else but i want
someone else like that's their type
thing i never had that that like oh i
really like this girl we had a thing and
then it's like
i want to get back you know what i mean
like oh yeah i never had uh in a
situation where i felt like that yeah i
i think it's more of a girl thing
because girls are like naturally
hypergamous you know what that means no
idea
i'm not well-versed
no this is like red pill knowledge so
basically hypergamous is like we have to
see the guy as the best we can do
otherwise we're not happy
okay like like men can set like you know
how women say like don't settle don't
settle like don't settle that's that's
hypergamy
because they're saying i can't settle
for anything but the best
because like over the course of human
history the women that survived were the
ones that could get the highest quality
male
so it's like
a girl dates a guy let's just do height
for example a girl dates a guy who's six
five he dumps her it doesn't work out
okay
nothing below six five will do for her
i've heard i've heard something about
this because um my friend actually he
got into a relationship with his with
this um you know he was quite tall you
know he was tattooed and whatever
and then they've dated for like three
maybe three and a half years like they
were like they were like like the
the number one couple in the you know
our little friendship group you know
everyone has one that like a couple that
sometimes you look at them like
like take it to the like get a room type
thing you know right
and it was like when they broke it off
it's like oh this girl took it like bad
and the guys that i've seen her day
after this always had to have tattoos
always had to be a certain answer i do
get what you're kind of i do get what
you're kind of saying yeah because like
uh there was
one situation where we had a discussion
about it and someone did mention it
saying like oh
like you bro like you
you destroyed this girl type thing you
fully destroyed her like her outlook on
men type thing because the only guys
that she did after that and it was for a
short period of time it was all like
tattoos with a beard with like a certain
feature yeah it looked like that that
guy yeah yeah so i do get what you're
saying so you don't think men have an
equivalent of that
i don't know i've heard this i don't
know if this is true but like i've heard
this whole thing about like
the first
love a man would have was his mum so he
tries to like
copy
the results type thing
so i'm not i don't know if that's any of
that's true chat if you know please let
me know but like i bel i don't i don't
feel like it but it's like
for me like i always said my perfect
height
when i was younger like when i was
younger and
younger sorry um
my perfect hair was like five five
but i'm not talking i'm not talking
about height i'm talking about like men
not being able to get over like one girl
from their past
so i used heidis as an example like the
girl has a hierarchy of things that she
looks for one of them is height but it
could be money it could be career it
could be personal like whatev whatever
is important to her but if the next guy
can't measure up to the last guy she's
always going to crave the last guy like
i said i
i was not able to be i couldn't say it
personally because i never actually got
put in a situation where i was like
feeling this type of way yeah i don't
think we have um
sorry i couldn't i was just wondering
someone says that they do have an
equivalent of that
um
interesting
do you have an equivalent to that i did
make you a mod lazaro appreciate it
okay what is the most frustrating thing
to you
about women in 2022
you get the mic you can complain all you
want
everything everything
like what do you think of what do you
think of modern women
that's a very very controversial topic
i love it i love it i need more men i
honestly need more men in the room to
back me on this because like
i'm like i'm basically a guy i'm on i'm
on your side i know you all i know you
all know but you know what it is it's
like it's
if i start coming like you know it's
just one of those things like it's so
big like you can't really like open your
mouth about those type of things too
much because there's obviously going to
be someone in the like in the chat the
females are watching they're gonna be
like no i'm not you know like that i'm
like it's like not this chat
that's true
but i'm saying do you think women lack
accountability today
like do you think that society kind of
babies us a little bit
little more now yes yeah yeah i'd say
that's i'd say even with like divorce
laws like you know women initiate
divorce 80 percent of the time
probably so yeah
if you're college you know what it is
yet and if you're college educated it's
90
why
why is that inaudible no it's hypergamy
is that an american yeah that's the
number but i would
no i would i guarantee it's the same
here because it's it's it's the way
women are so like if i
have a master's degree i don't so me
personally i don't value educate like
traditional like education
education yeah so i i this wouldn't work
for me but like let's say let's say
let's say i was a girl that really
valued education okay if i have a
master's degree i have to date a guy
with a master's degree or higher if i
make fifty thousand dollars i have to
date someone with fifty thousand like
like the number one reason that women
that um
indicator that a man's about to get
divorced
with i think eighty percent certainty
is if the woman out earns him
yeah that's that's that's happening
but like i did hear the thing about like
oh
um well i don't remember where i heard
it but there was a woman that was that
said it was like oh
a man this kind of like they see a
madness obviously today as far as they
still see a man as a provider type thing
but like if a woman out earns him it's
like
for some women that's a red flag because
like obviously i'm working more than you
so you're how are you not my [ __ ] like
you know i'm trying to say so obviously
that makes the man less attractive
but
i wouldn't and i mean aside it does
benefit women slightly more people in
that in that sense
so i'd say yeah i'd probably agree with
that a little bit
you can say a lot
i literally think we do i swear to god
because we take away the consequences
for women for everything
men get three times the jail time for
the same crime
there's no yeah but
women use ex
excuse me always they always have excuse
like gold for everything like
like literally like women have an excuse
for everything well no you know what
you're like
that like uh we've had like we had this
conversation before signing the lab like
the day that a woman has said sorry to a
man like that's a day like like like
baby sorry i was wrong about this you
was right like that's the day like a man
is like loki like he's just kind of like
okay i'm going to pour it
and there's there's so many girls that
have like a slight like disdain for men
you notice that like they'll say men are
trash like so quick
or like men are the problem or oh man
and i'm like why don't we just have this
distinct like what if
dudes were like oh [ __ ] like like
the whole thing about this like it's
it's it's one of those things where
if a woman was like calling this man
snap like if okay if we had like a group
of women and a group of men right in the
same room and the women are like
snapping at the man you are a piece of
[ __ ]
all of that and the man is just standing
there like no one would do anything no
one would do anything no and then
a man stops stopping me you are a [ __ ]
you're a whole you sleep everyone
it's like why why did you like five
minutes before she was talking about
your mama and your dad and your family
and she called you this and that they
sent that from every swear word known to
the mankind but me calling her a [ __ ]
knowing that that's true and knowing and
she knowing that that's right everyone's
going oh like like now that's stupid
like that's actually stupid because
words you know they are just words just
actions that you know lead to
consequences it's not words words would
words have meaning but as is the actions
that at the end of the day will get you
like you know in prison or whatever well
and it's almost like if a man
like calls the cops on a woman
you think he's going to be taken
seriously the cops would look at you
black seriously bruh like she came at me
with a knife
so
like it's almost it is that type of
thing like oh my wife is trying to kill
me she has a gun
like at that point it's just like bro
i've talked to a decent amount of guys
that were like domestically abused in a
relationship have you found that yeah
i've talked to guys like where girls
will like hit them and like go crazy
and
i've i've not dated in that in that
that's yeah
but
i mean that's pretty bad because you
notice i feel like that in that scenario
it's like if they're being like abused
and stuff by women and stuff but then
like they tried to flip at one time it
wouldn't work because the woman would be
like oh you know like like because you
know like um what she was thinking like
on some of the youtube videos i've seen
like one yes like the comedy ones where
like the woman slaps up a man and
nothing happens
but then as soon as the man like would
go like
maybe come down mm-hmm and they're like
oh you know yeah just get involved like
yeah women have as funny as the sounds
yeah women you should have an oscar for
every time you have an argument with
your mind because honestly approach you
are the best actors at acting like
you're hurt like someone punched you
like someone but you are the best hands
down i take my hat off to you i take my
hat off to you you should have an oscar
for every single time you get into an
argument with your man
oh it's just it's brilliant what's on
the side
wait so why do you think marriages are
failing today
you can't lay down with that good word i
can't let you
what wait if you're from uk you know
what i mean anyways
i don't wait no i
wait what did you say
i don't know because you know what is um
after a while
it's like you know um to use the car
analogies like you know when you when
you first get a car and it's got a new
car smell i think it's like it just
fades like with that i feel like that's
what it is because you have to in a
relationship i feel like
you have to
keep each other on your toes if that's
make if that makes sense and that's not
another keep it spontaneous like you
know come back to like
some it's always got to be different but
it's very hard to do with the same with
the same person like
if you see this person every single day
you go to sleep you wake up with them
you make you eat breakfast lunch and
dinner well not lunch so much but like
breakfast and dinner with that person so
keeping it like
continuously some people do it and
that's hey i'll take my hats off to you
as well like some people can manage it
too like i've seen i've seen um a couple
that's like was uh on steve harvey show
actually recently who was a hundred one
of them was 104 and the other one was
107. they've been married for like 80
something years 80 years some years
perfectly happy
and and
to quote them they said look you got to
you know you got to sit down and you got
to talk things out you got to see what
thing where where you want to go with
the things you know i'm saying i feel
like communication in a relationship is
key but in some marriages i feel like
once you kind of like get past the whole
like
um
well honeymoon stage and then after you
get past the whole uh marriage stage
it's like
i guess like i'd say people one of the
one of the parties just gets bored i
guess that's that's you know why do you
think it's um women that are leaving
like why why don't you think men are
leaving why is it only women
especially with the lack of wives today
i know what it is men are like look we
are sims we might not show it that's how
we get you but like we're sims like when
you when you're enraged you think you're
happy you're like you're a simple you
know simple like because look put you
this way so like every single guy group
here like you know how to be like boys
are for life like you know bros before
hoes and you know it's like it's like
your guys you would use analogy chicks
for before dicks typing and i mean it's
like the boys are going to be there
forever but one of one of the guys gets
in a relationship it's like you see him
less you go out yeah less like so then
your boys are going on with you i'm with
the girl yes because you're simply like
you're sitting here
you're having
you cooking food you know you're sipping
yeah that's it's something that happens
because you can't have a relationship
with
like girl simp as well when they're in a
relationship they're simple they'll tell
you that girl sometimes hey i'm gonna
stay in tonight you know you know she's
simping for the guy but he's like you
can't have a relationship with that word
where like there's no symptoms you can't
just have a girl it's like always
yeah mango you know it wouldn't work
obviously so one or the other always
seems that some a certain stage
yeah but then if they both simply why is
it the women that leave you just you
couldn't tell you i could i couldn't
honestly tell you like i mean does that
surprise you
not really do most of your friends that
have been in relationships to who
laughed for the majority
i don't have that many friends
i don't have any friends either that's
what we were talking you were telling me
i needed more friends yeah you
definitely no no you you definitely need
more friends you need to get out the
house what the i do get out of the house
i was just in ireland i was just in
ireland the other day after how long of
staying in those and you don't even go
to class
that's bad
i go to the gym every day that doesn't
come out how does that count
do you go who do you go to the gym with
all right if anyone's in london wants to
be my friend
[Music]
just just no no serial killer i cannot
believe that girl came all the way here
just to leave after five minutes oh yeah
we had a fan that basically was standing
outside the door and chose not to come
yeah guys you would not believe we
waited for this girl for like an hour
a fan i said i found one of the
interviews sorry yeah what would you say
we waited for her for an hour
about that because we're supposed to at
9 30 and we started like 10
was it 10 20. yeah yeah and then she
gets here and i'm like telling her how
to buzz in and she's like it's not
working and i know it's working because
he just used it so i'm telling her how
to do it
and i go down
to letter
and she's like oh never mind i left
i was like what the
i just i just sat here waiting for an
hour bye felicia
anyways so that's that's where we're at
today
this has been a struggle stream yeah a
little bit would you do audio problems
yeah we'll go through it we get we did
get through it and you're roasting me on
live
absolutely what'd you expect like you're
like
i had to one time close oh my god
okay
i'm trying to think of what else do you
want to ask you about marriage so you
don't care about a woman's money
you're you're not afraid of getting
married
and
are the divorce laws as bad in london
you don't know anything no idea this is
called this is called the blue pill
blue pill i don't know you know no
because i'm a sports person the only the
only thing that i have time for
personally is like i have to go to work
i have to go to university to do my
education and i have to
uh go training that's that's my that i
keep my life basic right if a woman
comes in into that and the woman clicks
with me i'll buy with her and i will
find time because look in a relationship
no matter what time no matter what you
do you could be business oriented you
could be whatever if you find someone
that you want to
um
do things with you'll find the time and
you'll find the time of day for to do
them things with
when girls be like oh i'm so like
i'm trying to focus on myself right now
and then the right guy comes along and
you know they they vibe she's going to
find it you know as funny as that she'll
find a time of day for that person
you know i mean so i'm i keep my life
pretty basic i don't get involved in the
whole like
like laws and stuff like that like
politics i don't really get involved
with that but that's just me that you
know everyone's different i just think
you can't live your life out of fear
like because i don't know i just feel
like
whenever i get married i'll just like do
it and if it goes wrong it goes wrong
like what else am i supposed to do
you've got a job like you know as you go
you gotta take you go take the deep
breath and jump off the cliff you know
it's just like yeah it's one of those
things
okay i'm kind of tired you're tired
i mean you did say you have two hours of
sleep so two hours guys but i'm kind of
i'm kind of dumb i stay up too late a
lot
and then i realized i was like oh my god
i have to leave for my game in two hours
ten dollars yay
thank you oh my gosh okay some sound
effects oh man wait no i have one
i
one of my to-do lists is to learn how to
use the sound board i know these are
these are noises but i don't know which
ones you don't know which ones
um
you know you can edit them right
no i know i know you can't yeah she's
not very well um
are you gonna help me i cannot i can
help you yeah yeah
okay um women leave their husbands for
the same reason a man converts his
religion changes his deepest idea wait
what okay women leave their husband for
the same reason a man converts his
religion changes his deepest ideological
belief she does not believe in you
anymore and never did men are to women
as god is to man
did you get that
no not really basically like if a woman
doesn't believe in you anymore
she's gonna like she's about to leave
your house
yeah that was um i don't oh
my mom was going but there was one thing
that was um
i think i think i read it somewhere but
basically it's like a man will go
we'll do so much will change so much
things for like for a woman yeah like to
change the way he like the dresses
change the way he talks whatever to fit
in that woman just to find out that the
woman is no longer interested in him
that's like
that's
that's a bit bad in it because like he's
done so much for that person
to
like fit in you don't think
see because part of me kind of thinks
it's your own fault though
because like you chose to do all that
you know what i mean
yeah like and you should kind of read
the signs like most girls most girls
that's what girls nowadays is like oh
when a guy does those nice things they
are not they get unnoticed
right and then when a guy is doing like
they're like oh they're all all guys are
[ __ ] boys yeah we are going to be
because when we when we chose you and we
did everything to do the best that we
could for you and you was like nah let
me go do this with this guy and then
that guy [ __ ] him over and then you
start thinking every guy's a [ __ ] boy
but that guy that was actually there for
you when you cried whenever because she
wanted to be with you yeah they don't
get noticed do they no
guys he's a little red pill that's a red
pill
nice nice guys finish lost man like the
hell
um nice guys do sometimes
okay guys i'm gonna this is gonna be a
quick stream tonight
an hour
yeah yeah it's gonna be a quicker stream
thank you so much for the super chats
you guys um i brought on a blue pill guy
blue pill guy blue pill we can't we
can't repel him completely yet but maybe
i'm trying i'm trying my best like you
by the end of this you gotta be very
skeptical of women you have to like even
me you gotta say is she a chameleon
yeah
yeah
change color
no no the chameleon is like um
debating like like you think i'm i'm not
i don't actually think what i say
you have to you have to
oh kind of like when you say you're fine
and you're not fine right
that type of thing like baby okay i'm
fine like what okay guys they really
want me to join this stream on my phone
so i'm about to
but thank you so much for the super
chats i appreciate you guys so much um
don't forget to subscribe and guys
seriously if you want to lose weight buy
the meal plan i swear to god you will
lose weight you will feel the best you
have ever felt in your life i
could not lose 20 pounds i was trying to
lose 20 pounds for like three years and
i literally couldn't it's cooking with
chris the link is in the description
um you're gonna be like slim thick i
swear to god okay tell them where they
can find you
that's why i said i saw the video no i i
do it twice oh you do this
because sometimes people it's new people
yeah nah so you can find me on instagram
um i have two accounts one of them is
david as underscore golovchanka and the
other one is why possible
why possible underscore fitness
you can also find me on youtube on why
possible tv and
i think that's it facebook is lava does
go off jungle but i don't think anyone
uses facebook anymore
okay guys don't forget to subscribe to
the channel ring that notification bell
so you'll be notified when i'm live
and i'll talk to you guys next